6,7,9,5,4,5,6,7,8,9.
Ich bin Robin, ich hab das eigentlich gesagt, aber ist ja egal.
Hallo Robin, ist Windows.
Ich wollte eigentlich mit euch mal kurz über das Thema sprechen, auch zum Thema fangesteuerte Router, also sprich fangesteuert durch den Internet Service Provider. Und ihr habt ja vorhin schon ein bisschen geredet, dass wir über Sicherheitslücken in Routern sowohl durch WLAN als auch über das Internet. Und mir ist da eigentlich so ein bisschen auch der Gedanke gekommen, ich hab da auch schon ein bisschen was drüber gelesen, wenn jetzt sozusagen ein Provider wie jetzt nach der Telekom mit diesem Deepboard Router zum Beispiel ein anderer Provider die Möglichkeit hat, den Router sozusagen über die eigene Server zu provisionieren und zu steuern, gäbe es ja eigentlich theoretisch auch die Möglichkeit, das wurde vorhin schon irgendwie hier gesagt, so ein Router könnte ja auch Bitcoins berechnen, so ein Botnetz irgendwie mit betreiben, gäbe ja eigentlich dann auch für die Möglichkeit vom Provider theoretisch irgendwas einzusteuern in der Router oder mich auch irgendwie vielleicht auszuspionieren, was ich so in meinem Netzwerk zum Beispiel noch habe.
Der Provider hat jederzeit die Möglichkeit, dir auch deinem Router, wenn es einer von denen ist, eine neue Firmware überzuhelfen und rein technisch gesehen hat der Provider jederzeit die Möglichkeit, dir da ein verbundesverstaatstreuernerten Router hinzustellen, also irgendeine Firmware, die schon auf dem Router in deinem Netzwerk zu Hause rumschnüffelt. Das können die rein technisch gesehen jederzeit sofort machen und auch ohne, dass du irgendwie da großen Überblick drüber hast.
Dafür brauchen die nicht mal Provisionierung.
Ohne, dass er einen großen Überblick hat oder ohne, dass überhaupt jemand einen großen Überblick darüber hat. Also würde man das überhaupt merken?
Na ja, da sind halt schon physikalisch die Bits im Flash deines Routers andere als vorher waren. Okay, aber wer guckt sich das an?
Na ich jeden Morgen.
Genau, morgens erst mal Bits zählen.
Aber dein Provider hat eh eine Übersicht über deinen kompletten Traffic, den kriegt er eh und den leitet er auch auf Anfrage zu Strafverfolgungsbehörden usw. Aber bei sowas wie Kabelnetzen ist eh hinter dem Modem, vor dem Modem, also was man also an Broadcast Traffic in so einem Doxys-Segment an einem Kabelnetz hinter seinem Modem wieder sieht von anderen Leuten ist spannend.
Weil jetzt zum Beispiel wenn es der Provider Zugriff hat, ich meine klar, dass der Provider natürlich meinen Traffic, den ich über das Internet rausjage und den ich irgendwie dazugespielt bekomme, über das Netz das sehen kann. Das ist mir klar, weil zum Beispiel eben über so einen freigesteuerten Looter, das macht ja einem auch zum Beispiel die Fehlkommensmachkraft, dass man zum Beispiel auch über das Kundencenter dann den Looter direkt steuern kann, quasi auch gar nicht mehr über die IP-Adresse da einloggen muss. Dann könnte ja theoretisch auf der Provider zum Beispiel vielleicht mal schauen, was mache ich in meinem Netzwerk oder auch wenn ich zum Beispiel irgendwie eine ungefützte Freigabe habe, weil ich mir denke, okay, mein Netzwerk ist geschützt, zum Beispiel aus WLAN. Könnte ja theoretisch über den Looter auch zum Beispiel auch auf eine Netzwerksfreigabe zugreifen und sowas.
In dem Moment, wo dein Provider sowas machen kann, gehört dir der Looter halt nicht. Also das sehe ich genauso wie mit Telefonen und allen anderen Hardware, auf denen ich nicht der einzige Herr im Hause bin und auf das Gerät quasi exklusiv Zugriff habe. So das ist dann halt eine Box, die dir nicht gehört, sondern deinem Anbieter. Und deswegen ist sowas halt schon sehr fragwürdig, ob die Vorteile, die man daraus gewinnt, dass irgendwie was flüssiger funktioniert und man jetzt eine Voice-over-IP-Telefone nicht konfigurieren muss, sondern das der Anbieter tut. Also ich weiß nicht den Vorteil von so einem Kundenportal im Internet gegenüber. Ich muss mich lokal auf eine Adresse einloggen. Sehe ich nicht, wenn ich dafür das Hausrecht auf meinem Plastorouter zu Hause verliere. Wobei eh die Frage ist, ob man der einzige Herr auf dem Gerät ist, weil die Software auf diesen Boxen ist jetzt nicht unbedingt von...
Ich würde da jetzt an der Stelle noch nicht so viel den Fokus auf die Plastorouter legen, weil was du dir allein mit deinem Mobiltelefon, wo ja irgendwie so ein verbogenes Betriebssystem drauf ist, dort in dein Heimnetzwerk reinschleppst, wo die Nachbarn drauf Zugriff haben, wie die dir dann rumwüten, ist es einfach so, dass dein irgendwie übers WLAN angeschlossene Rechner in deinem Zuhause sind, einfach nicht mehr so zu betrachten, als wenn sie isoliert stünden. Also du musst eh aufpassen, dass das nicht mehr dein privates Netzwerk ist und jeder, der da drin irgendwie seinen Fuß in der Tür hat, kann auch schauen, welcher Traffic da abgeht. Das ist jetzt alles nicht so schlimm, finde ich. Man muss sich nur bewusst werden, dass die Zeit, wo dein einzelner PC dort eine Verbindung mit Mode, mit dem Internet hat, die ist vorbei. Inzwischen kann man sich in deinem Heimnetzwerk so an ziemlich vielen Punkten auch bequem machen. Aber der Router ist schon noch an einer etwas exponierteren Stelle, weil du ihn ja meistens danach fragst, wenn du mal DNS, also Internetadressen aufgelöst haben möchtest, dann ist der DNS Server meistens dein Router. Und dann weiß der, egal wie du da verschlüsselte Verbindungen machst oder nicht, weißt zumindest dein Router, auf welchen Webseiten du dich rumgetrieben hast. Egal was jetzt dein Firefox oder dein Chrome, in welchem Modus du dich da bewegt hast.
Das ist halt das Gerät, das dir dein Internet zu Hause liefert. Und das ist an genau der Stelle, an der man einhaken kann, um dir irgendwelche Antworten zu geben, die jetzt nicht das Internet sind, sondern ja.
Und vor allem du merkst es nicht. Also keine Firewall, kein Antivirus-Programm, irgendwas im Heimnetzwerk kann das detaktieren, weil das halt der Knotenpunkt ist. Das ist das Gateway zum Internet. Das ist die einzige Stelle, wo der ganze Traffic rübergeht.
Ja klar, also deshalb hab ich bei mir zu Hause zum Beispiel auch eine Fritzbox angeklemmt und hab den Speedfall-Router einfach mal, um halt zumindest etwas sicherer zu gehen und weil die Fritzbox noch ein bisschen mehr bietet. Wobei, so hat der Freund schon gesagt, diese Maligations-Telefonen jetzt auch gerade eben zum Thema so DNS und so. Ich hab's dann irgendwann so gemacht, bei mir ging das nämlich dann auch irgendwann auf den Keg. Ich hab dann irgendwann noch mal im eigenen Server einfach ein Bind-DNS-Server installiert und hab dann da einfach mein eigenes Zeug eingestellt und hab dann gar nicht mehr überhaupt die DNS-Server von der Telekom.
Bietet die Fritzbox denn eigentlich wirklich mehr oder macht die nur den Eindruck, als würde sie mehr bieten, weil man mehr drauf rumklicken muss?
Also ich find's zu meinen, finde ich, dass das Interface von der Fritzbox ein bisschen leichter ist und du bekommst nicht angezeigt. Zum Beispiel, ich benutze jetzt Mac OS und wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung hab, als ich da auf diesen Sweeper-Router draufgegangen bin von der Telekom, hieß es dann schon wegen, ja, ich würde einen nicht so schützten Browser verwenden, sozusagen Nutzung auf eigenes Risiko. Das hab ich bei der Fritzbox zumindest mal nicht. Und dann hat die Fritzbox halt natürlich auch ein paar nette Funktionen, so zum Beispiel eben was zum Beispiel das WLAN angeht, dass man eben schauen kann, okay, welcher Kanal kann ich mir jetzt irgendwie, welchen kann ich mir selbst raussuchen, wo ist jetzt irgendwie, hat der Nachbar noch irgendwie drauf, wo kann ich wieder am besten senden. Und dann hat die Fritzbox ja noch verschiedene Funktionen, dass man eben sagen kann, okay, man weiß irgendwie immer so wöchentlich irgendwie eine Statistik haben, wie viel Traffic irgendwie angefallen ist, wo man überall so hinterfoniert hat und so.
Also sie bieten tatsächlich.
Dass man das dann vielleicht mal irgendwie so vergleichen kann mit der Rechnung, die man dann irgendwie am Ende bekommt. Beispielsweise unter einem Buch.
Das ist tatsächlich das Einzige, worüber sich diese Router differenzieren, weil unter der Haube läuft halt dieselbe Software drunter. Das ist, wie groß, das ist alles Linux. Es gibt ein paar wenige Geräte, auf denen vielleicht VXWorks läuft, weil man sich den Flash sparen wollte und nicht so viele Funktionen braucht. Aber im Prinzip ist das alles tatsächlich auch freie Software. Nur gibt es gerade bei besagter Box zum Beispiel das Problem, dass diese Unternehmen sich da halt bedienen und sich so zu hin frickeln. Das hat funktioniert. Aber zum einen die Veränderungen, die sie da machen, nicht an die Community zurückgeben. Oder nur, nachdem man sie ganz doll angepeakt hat, und da ist auch juristisch.
Da muss man dazu sagen, dass diese Software ursprünglich unter einer Lizenz veröffentlicht worden ist, die genau das von einem fordert, wenn man sie kommerziell verwendet, mindestens, dass dort alle Weiterentwicklungen wieder zurückgegeben werden. Steht da eine Lizenz drinnen und da gibt es auch befreundete Anwälte, die sich da das zur Aufgabe gemacht haben, diese Lizenz, diese GPL dort auch durchzusetzen.
Da kann man von leben wahrscheinlich, ne?
Als Anwalt?
Ja, Anwaltfragen ja eben. Robin, schönen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Danke.
Trigger Happy Finger hier.
Ja, ist tatsächlich so, weil in dem Moment, wo so ein Hersteller einen Bug fixt, was sie eh selten tun, die fricken sich meist nur so hin, dass es gerade funktioniert. Da kann vielleicht Mirko ein bisschen mehr zu erzählen, weil die Router differenzieren sich.
Weil der hat es kaputt gemacht.
Ja, also man kann auf jeden Fall den Fokus darauf legen, wie oft Hersteller Updates rausgeben für Router. Also das Verhältnis ist eh ziemlich krass, wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, dass zum Beispiel 500 verschiedene Hardware-Modelle im Feld sind, dann kann man sagen, dass vielleicht das Doppelte oder höchstens das Dreivoran unterschiedlichen Softwareversionen für diese Router existiert. Das heißt, pro Router werden im Durchschnitt höchstens zwei bis drei Updates durchgegeben oder maximal.
Wenn überhaupt, also es gibt Router, die irgendwie mit der Software ausgeliefert werden und das war's dann und dann gibt es wieder welche, wo für die es drei, vier oder fünf, aber das ist die Minderszahl.
Aber am Ende muss man sich vorstellen, dass dieses, genau dieses Betriebssystem, was da ständig Meldungen hat, dass da dieses Programm und dieses Programm Fehler hat, um einen beliebigen Code darauf auszuführen, dass dieses Betriebssystem, was ja eigentlich schon im Internet ständig man hinterherpatchen muss und dass dort ziemlich viele bezahlte Leute in großen Firmen ständig dabei sind, alle Fehler zu korrigieren und die dann im Wochentakt neu zu machen. Und genau sowas hat man da eigentlich auch am Internet. Das heißt, man stellt sie zu Hause hin, man hat eine öffentliche IP-Adresse und es damit aus dem Internet zu erreichen. Und es gibt auch Leute, die sich dann so als Sport mal eingerichtet haben, das gesamte Internet abzugrasen und mal nachzugucken, wer da lauscht, wer da guckt. Und im Optimalfall rauszufinden, genau welche Version von welchem kleinen Plast-Router mit welcher Software das da drauf ist.
Und wenn man dann einmal so einen Fehler gefunden hat, den man ausnutzen kann, dann hat man ein Jackpot, weil es gibt halt nicht nur eine von diesen Boxen, sondern ein paar Hunderttausende. Und ja.
Es gab ein Projekt von Leuten, die wollten das gesamte Internet einmal scannen und konnten das natürlich nicht mit einem oder zwei Rechnern machen, auch nicht mit Hunderten oder Tausenden. Und haben sich deswegen bestimmte Router ausgesucht, die halt Sicherheitslücken hatten und haben die missbraucht, um halt Teile des Internets zu scannen und die Statistiken dann halt an einen zentralen Server zu senden. Und somit haben sie es wirklich geschafft, mit Hilfe von Zehntausenden von Routern, die halt zu Hause stehen, das Internet abzugrasen. Und das war halt noch ein sehr humaner Fall. Sie haben die Bandbreite limitiert. Sie haben keine Rückstände auf den Routern zurückgelassen. Aber sie hätten halt durchaus Schadcode auf die Router laden können. Und mit Sicherheit, man weiß, dass auf den meisten oder echt vielen Routern Schadcode ist, die halt die Router zu einem Teil von einem Botnetz machen.
Na ja, das heißt auf den meisten Routern. Aber man kann mit Sicherheit davon ausgehen, dass in so ziemlich allen Routern, die da derzeit deployed sind, mindestens eine kritische Sicherheitslücke existiert, die sowas ermöglicht.
Kann ich das dann sehen als User? Also als Ich-User, nicht als User.
Das ist ja genau das, was man als Botnetz-Betreiber möchte, dass du das genau nicht siehst. Also du merkst dann vielleicht, deine Box wird ein bisschen heiß, aber so ein Botnetz funktioniert natürlich nur, wenn der Bot lange genug funktioniert und wenn dem Benutzer das nicht auffällt. Also es sind die besten Bots, die lange überleben auf dem Gerät. Im Fall von diesem Cana Botnet war es tatsächlich sogar so, dass der keine Daten auf dem Gerät verändert hat, sondern nur im Rahmen gelaufen ist, weil auf Überwachungskameras und Industriesteuerungen hast du nicht gesehen, da brauchst du dich nicht speichern. Das ist zum einen noch mal ein anderer Level, was so die Bösartigkeit angeht und auch die Gefahr, dass ein Gerät dadurch kaputt geht. Das wollten sie natürlich nicht. Und eben nicht auffallen, dass das Gerät nicht neu gestartet wird und der Bot wieder weg ist.
Sie haben es dann Volkszählung, also Tensus 2013 genannt, was ziemlich nett der Name für das Projekt ist.
Haben wir denn interessante Daten dabei rausgefunden? Ist es irgendwie als Arzt genutzt oder hat es nur Spaß gemacht?
420 Millionen aktive Rechner im Internet gefunden, also die auf Pinks geantwortet haben und entsprechend online waren.
Alleine diese Zahl zu wissen, ist schon geil irgendwie.
Ja, weiß man zwar auch nicht, wie so eine Zahl, die dann einfach, muss man doch mal ausrechnen, wie viel das in Kilogramm oder in China-Containern oder... Genau.
Wie viele iPads das sind. 24 Millionen vermutlich.
Auf deiner Seite, wenn man sich überlegt, 420 Millionen mal dein DSL, lass die irgendwie alle mit 384 Kilobit angebunden sein im Schnitt, macht schon ordentlich Bums. Wenn man die alle auf seiner Seite hat und dann mal jemanden ärgern möchte, dann macht das schon Bums. Da kann man schon irgendwie so ein größeres Ziel mal aus dem Netz befördern.
Die 9.01 Spammer. Chaosradio, 188, es geht uns um Ruta heute Abend.
Der Nibbler, der Mörk und der Erdreiß sind im Studio und die 0331 70 97 160 angerufen hat der Nicky.
Hallo Nicky. Die Nicky, verdammt.
Hallo die Nicky.
Ja.
Ich hatte angerufen, weil vorhin ja die Frage war, welche so die schlimmsten Kunden sind, die angerufen haben.
Du arbeitest an einer Hotline.
Ich habe gearbeitet ja eine ganze Weile, zwei Jahre lang.
Bei wem?
Bei der Telekom als technischer Support.
Muss man dafür eigentlich was können oder habt ihr auch als technischer Support ein Protokoll, das ihr abarbeitet?
Wir haben auch ein Protokoll da. Das ist quasi eine Arbeitsanweisung, was wir zu machen haben und was nicht quasi.
Ach ja, da steht auch, was ihr nicht zu machen habt?
Es sind halt solche Sachen, wenn das und das Problem dann leite, an den und den weiter und wenn das und das dann an den und den und so.
Das heißt selbst wenn du genügend Sachverstand hättest, das Problem zu lösen, darfst du es nicht?
Teilweise ja, weil es dann halt auf die Anrufzeit geht.
Ach du hast doch nur eine bestimmte Zeit, die du mit den Leuten reden darfst?
So theoretisch gesehen ja, man hat dann so seine Normwerte, die und die Zeit sollte es nicht überschreiten und wenn man dann irgendwie zwei Stunden mit dem Kunden am machen ist, dann kommen sie an und sagen, du machst jetzt aber schon zwei Stunden, überleg mal, mach mal hinne.
Darfst du dann einfach auflegen?
Nein.
Echt nicht so, Arschloch, klick.
Hallo, ich kann Sie nicht mehr hören, hallo, rufen Sie bitte nochmal an.
Wenn der Kunde, sag ich mal beleidigt wird, dann darf man auflegen, aber sonst muss man immer warten, bis der Kunde auflegt.
Das geht auch in die Statistik mit ein, also zumindest habe ich das in einem Unternehmen mal gesehen, dass das tatsächlich ein Faktor ist, der in die persönliche Bewertung einzieht, die neben der Länge, wie er aufgelegt hat.
Richtig, ja. Das ist tatsächlich auch so.
Super, aber erzähl mal von den Kunden, mit dem spannenden Kram, los.
Ich hatte in den zwei Jahren einige Kunden, die wirklich außerordentlich doof waren, würde ich mal sagen. Einer zum Beispiel hatte angerufen, weil das Internet nicht funktionierte und ich sagte ihm halt so, dann gucken wir mal auf den Router drauf. Welche Leuchten sind denn gerade an oder eben nicht an? Und er sagt, er kann nicht drauf gucken. Da habe ich dann halt gefragt, warum. Ob irgendwie er vom Telefon nicht weg kann oder wie auch immer. Und er sagt, das Haus ist jetzt so ungefähr ein halbes Jahr alt. Und als ich das gebaut habe, habe ich halt den Router mit eingemauert.
Da hat jemand Vertrauen ins Produkt.
Ich habe gedacht, ich muss mir erstmal das Headset abnehmen und muss erstmal eine Runde lachen, damit er das nicht mitkriegt. Und ich habe echt gedacht, das ist der Wahnsinn. Kann ja ja sein.
Hallo, Telefon streich den Boden. Was geht denn auf Ihrem Schirm? Knirps.
Ich kann mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen, dass man sowas, also ich kann mir keine geistige Disposition vorstellen, die dazu führt, dass man seinen Router einmauert.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie er drauf gekommen ist. Keine Ahnung.
Das ist fast wie Zahnbürste einmauern.
Und dann hast du ihm gesagt, dann hol dir ein Stemmeisen und...
Ich hab ihn dann gebeten, dass er sich darum kümmern soll, dass das Ding rauskommt und dann kann er sich gerne wieder melden, wenn es dann noch Probleme gibt.
Setzen Sie sich mal hin. Wie fest ist das denn eingemauert? Wie dick ist denn die Mauer?
In Amerika wärst du verklagt worden dafür. Stand nämlich nicht drauf, dass man das nicht kann.
In Amerika wurdest du einfach mit der Faust durch die Wand, weil das ist nicht weit und danach wieder zumacht. Da stellt sich das Problem nicht.
Das war so einer der schlimmsten, die ich hatte, aber es gab noch viele andere.
Hat er denn verstanden, was das Problem ist, als du dann genug gelacht hattest und gesagt hast, ja pass mal auf, hat er das kapiert oder hat er gedacht?
Nach einigen diskutieren hat er es dann eingesehen, dass wir schon wissen müssten, was mit dem Rute eigentlich los ist und dass wenn er getauscht werden muss, er dann sowieso raus müsste. Das hat er dann irgendwie schon, aber ich muss ihn davon überzeugen.
Ich meine, das war ja wahrscheinlich auch so ein Telekom-Router. Die sehen ja schon so aus, als würden sie zügig kaputt gehen. So was mauer ich doch nicht ein. Ich meine, wenn das Ding irgendwie aus, aus irgendwie, aus dem Augen, aus dem Kopf, aus dem V2A irgendwie stahl.
Oder das Züchselmodium noch.
Ja genau und mit so tierisch dicken Goldanschlüssen oder irgendwie sowas, dann würde ich sagen, aus dem Augen, aus dem Sinn.
Vielleicht wollt ihr einfach so dieses Plasteding da nicht im Zimmer stehen haben, kann ich auch nachvollziehen.
Ja natürlich kann ich auch, aber dann mache ich eine Aussparung in der, naja, da brauchen wir nicht drüber zu reden.
Ja das war so einer der interessantesten, die ich da überhaupt dabei hatte. Also den werde ich wahrscheinlich auch meinen restlichen Leben nicht vergessen, weil der einfach so bescheuert war.
Was sind denn die angenehmsten eigentlich? Wie kann man euch hotline leuten? Weil ihr seid ja eigentlich die armen Schweine, die da irgendwie in vorderster Front stehen und immer erst zuerst abkriegen. Wie kann man euch denn eigentlich eine Freude machen?
Vermutlich nicht anrufen.
Oder das Protokoll schon kennen und die ganzen Antworten geben.
Ansonsten war es immer hilfreich, wenn die Leute Ahnung hatten auf jeden Fall. Und dann von vornherein sagen konnten, okay das hat er gemacht, das war schon mal eine große Hilfe. Oder wenn man einfach freundlich war und das gemacht hat, was man ihm gesagt hat. Da gab es dann auch viele, wo man dann sagt, okay dann gehen sie mal in den Rechner, probieren das und das mal aus. Und dann sagt er dann auf einmal, ja ich habe aber jetzt das, das, das, das gemacht. Und du denkst, ja dann fangen wir jetzt nochmal von vorn an, dann machen sie das, das, das, das.
Dann fassen sie jetzt mal die beiden Kabel an, die da aus der Wand kommen.
Entweder man hat Ahnung oder man hält einfach den Mund und macht, was gesagt wird. Gut.
Ist das ein guter Job oder ist das ein schlimmer Job?
Stress? Im Call Center hat man ja viel Stress durch die vielen Anrufe, aber normalerweise fände ich es eigentlich von der Arbeit her in sich ganz in Ordnung.
Das ist ja abwechslungsreich. Weil jedes Mal, wenn das Telefon klingelt und man jemand dran hat, weiß man noch nicht, wo es hin und her geht.
Das ist wie so eine Hörertalk Sendung hier.
Und was natürlich hilfreich ist auch, wenn man Leute spricht, die auch wirklich Deutsch reden und wissen, wovon man redet. Das hatte ich nämlich auch öfter, dass dann die türkische Mutter angerufen hat mit ihren drei Kindern und die gingen ihr tierisch auf die Sackweise kein Fernsehen gucken wollen, weil das entertainment lief und sie konnten mir überhaupt nicht sagen, was überhaupt die Sache ist.
Das ist vielleicht auch nicht eine Frage der ethnischen oder der sprachlichen, sondern dass man einfach irgendwo auf einem Level ist und das, was man rüberbringt, auf der anderen Seite ankommt und umgekehrt.
Das ist natürlich klar. Nur wenn es dann eben so weit ist, dass wirklich nur ein Bröckchen Deutsch verstanden oder gesprochen wird, dann ist das halt schwierig. Ich kann ja nicht jede Sprache der Welt.
Habt ihr da nicht einen solchen Mitarbeiter für? Weil ich kann mir vorstellen, dass in einem großen Unternehmen man jetzt schon für irgendwie Deutsch, Englisch klar, vielleicht Türkisch, vielleicht Französisch. Spanisch. Das darf schon so die Spanisch die häufigsten Fälle sein.
Es gab oder es gibt auch nach wie vor Hotlines direkt für russische Leute. Ich glaube, es war russisch, türkisch, polnisch glaube ich auch und Englisch.
Aber das ist das ist in den normalen Hotline Prozessen nicht drin, dass du sagst, okay, sprich türkisch, ich leite sofort weiter. Das heißt, du hast nur noch die Wahl, irgendwelche Kommandos zu bellen, in der Hoffnung, dass derjenige, der kaum Deutsch spricht, wenigstens den Befehl versteht.
Lüttven Reset. Internet Jock.
Nicky, wir danken für deinen Anruf.
Gute Nacht, Tschüss.
Telefon zu Pirtual.
Nein, das war genau die fünf Worte Türkisch.
Verstehe.
Chaos Radio 188, die Musik kommt immer noch von Kirill Sergeyev zu finden auf mixotic.net. Und es ist das Mix tape Nummer 48. Was ist da ist Chaos Radio 188 beschäftigt sich mit Routern. Ich hab jetzt Angst, weil meine Fritzbox ist heiß.
Eine Plast-Router.
Plast-Router, Verzeihung. Meine Fritzbox ist heiß und eben habt ihr gesagt, da könnte ja jetzt durchaus auch so ein Bot, das könnte ja Teil eines Botnetzes sein, dass jemand meine Fritzbox übernommen hat. Wie finde ich denn raus, ob das so ist?
Der einfachste Weg ist einfach nicht rausfinden, sondern einfach wieder neu machen.
Neue Fritzbox kaufen?
Ne, neue Firmware drauf. Ist ja irgendwie eigentlich was immer so, auch der Tipp ist, wenn dein Zuhause-Rechner infiziert ist, einfach mach noch ein Backup von den wichtigsten Daten und danach setzten neu auf und bei so einem Router ist es ja nun nicht ganz so doll schwer, weil es ja nun nicht so viel Flash drinne und dann...
Immer wieder Zeit für ein Firmware-Update.
Genau. Aber da du ja da eh nur über das Netz drauf zugreifen kannst, ist es halt ein bisschen blöd, weil der könnte dir einfach vortäuschen. Naja, ich hab die neue Firmware da jetzt grad eingespielt, ist alles in Ordnung. Also ist auch nicht so...
Das heißt eigentlich hab ich keine Chance.
Du kannst dich zwischen deinem Router und deiner Telefondose stecken und den Traffic mitsniffen und gucken, ob dort irgendwas ungewöhnliches ist. Aber das ist bestimmt die nette wenigsten.
Das könnte man bestimmt als Dienstleistung anbieten. Das Problem ist ja immer, dass so Typen wie ich, die verstehen halt, was das Problem ist, aber sind zu doof eine Lösung, sich irgendwie einfallen zu lassen oder die vorhandenen Lösungen zu benutzen. Und ich glaube, so Typen, wenn du an solche Leute rangehst...
Wie Netzkammerjäger.
Ja, sowas. Ich wäre halt auch bereit, und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das sehr viele sind, dafür sogar Geld zu bezahlen, dass jemand kommt, dem ich vertraue, der guckt und sagt, nee, ist in Ordnung.
Kann ich machen. Ich komm vorbei, sag, ist in Ordnung. Aber natürlich kann man ja versuchen zu verhindern, dass sich überhaupt Software auf deinem Rechner oder auf deinem Plastirouter da einnistet, indem du einfach eine eigene außergewöhnliche Distribution da einspielst. Indem du da einfach was aus dem Internet, da gibt es ja auch inzwischen was von Rationfarben für viele gängige Router, und dann fährst du halt zum Beispiel ein Open VRT drauf oder so ein NetBSD. Da gab es auch so ein Monowall.
Aber da habe ich ja dann wieder das Problem, dass ich das überhaupt nicht mehr verstehe, oder? Oder ist das auch so clicky bundy für Dove?
Das ist inzwischen auch schon fast clicky bundy für Dove. Wäre aber auch mal eine schöne Möglichkeit jetzt für dich, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen, zu gucken, was da so im Kern dir zu Hause Internet macht. Das ist so, glaube ich, inzwischen so Haushaltsgrundlagenwissen, denke ich mal, sollte man für den Internetführer scheiden. So grob zu wissen, was es ist, was einem Internet macht.
Zumindest für die Gewichtsklasse B.
Das Internet hat zum Beispiel OpenWrt, also eine freie Linux-Distribution für Router, Router. Läuft auf wirklich vieler Hardware und vielen Gateways und Routern, die zu Hause stehen. Und da kann man sich ruhig einfach mal informieren. Da gibt es halt Auflistungen von Hardware, wo das drauf laufen könnte und entsprechend die alternative Firmware installieren.
Wie viele gibt es denn da so gerade? Wie viele verschiedene offene Firmware-Projekte für so Plast-Router und auf wie viele verschiedene Plast-Router laufen die? Läuft dann alles auf eben oder?
Nee, also die Hersteller, die ändern ja auch immer ihre Hardware und von daher wird es schwer. Also es muss halt portiert werden. Es muss halt initial einmal OpenWrt auf dieser Box portiert werden. Da sich aber die Hardware nur marginal unterscheidet, meistens ist es relativ einfach. Und OpenWrt läuft auf geschätzt 100, 200 Routern unterschiedlichen Modellen.
Du siehst du Holgi.
Da hab ich ja was zu tun.
Läuft das noch auf allen Fritz-Boxen, dieses OpenWrt?
Leider nicht. Nicht? Weil die Fritz-Boxen teilweise Chips drin haben, wie zum Beispiel von Broadcom, die keine offenen Quellsourcen für ihre Chips bereitstellen. Und das leider sehr schwierig ist, dort den Support drauf zu portieren.
Aber die verwenden doch da auch so einen Linux. Warum können die das anpassen, ohne die Quellen zurückgeben zu müssen?
Das ist wie immer dieser GPL-Streit. Die GPL sollte eigentlich vorsehen, dass sie die Sourcen bereitstellen sollen. Allerdings versuchen sie, sich daraus zu winden, mit irgendwelchen Argumentationen, die teilweise als valide, teilweise nicht angesehen wären. Und das sind halt immer Rechtsstreitereien.
Nein, das heißt, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass die vor Gericht sagen, ja, hier GPL interessiert uns nicht, gucken Sie, Herr Richter, da, Fritz Box, das ist kein Computer, da ist kein Monitor, keine Tastatur dran, da Lizenz, Software.
Das ist kein Scherz, das haben sie wirklich gebracht.
Das ist kein Computer, sonst könnt ihr Schach spielen. Wir machen Nachrichten, danach ist Chaosradio 188 wieder da, um Ruta geht's heute.
Also ich persönlich finde Fritz ja ganz unmöglich, so etwas wie Fritz in meinem schönen Nordkorea, wenn da jeder seine eigene Meinung sagen könnte und die Leute so richtige, echte Informationen kriegen würden.
Und dazu noch diese rebellische Musik.
Da wäre ich ja die längste Zeit Diktator, Staatsoberhaupt gewesen.
Außerdem kenne ich doch mein Volk.
Meine Nordkoreaner werden viel zu gern unterdrückt.
Da macht so was wie Rundfunkbeitrag für unabhängige Medien gar keinen Sinn, wa?
Fritz, unabhängig durch euren Rundfunkbeitrag.
In Italien ist die Bildung einer neuen Regierung gescheitert. Die Sondierungsgespräche des Linkspolitikers Pierluigi Bersani mit den anderen Parteien waren nicht erfolgreich. Das hat Bersani am Abend Italiens Staatspräsident Napolitano mitgeteilt. Die Regierungsbildung ist schwierig, weil aus der Wahl Ende Februar drei nahezu gleich starke Lager hervorgegangen waren, ohne dass es einen eindeutigen Sieger gab. Journalisten, die für den Münchner NSU-Prozess zugelassen sind, dürfen ihren Platz jetzt doch mit anderen Reportern tauschen. Das hat das Oberlandesgericht München entschieden. Bei der Vergabe der 50 festen Plätze waren Journalisten von türkischen Medien leer ausgegangen, obwohl die meisten Opfer der Neonazi-Mordserie einen türkischen Migrationshintergrund hatten. Dies hatte im In- und Ausland scharfen Protest ausgelöst. Grundsätzlich, so das Münchner Gericht, bleibe es jedoch bei der Akkreditierungsliste. Sie werde nicht erweitert. Drei Raumfahrer sind von einem Weltraumbahnhof in Kasachstan zu einem Rekordflug ins All gestartet. Die beiden Russen und ein Amerikaner wollen innerhalb von sechs Stunden, also noch in der Nacht, die internationale Raumstation ISS erreichen. Bislang waren für so eine Reise zwei Tage nötig. Das neue Sechs-Stunden-Schema wurde möglich, da der digitale Bordcomputer nun unabhängig vom Flugleitzentrum arbeitet. Ein ständiger Funkkontakt mit dem Boden ist nicht mehr nötig. In Lübbenau sollen ab dem Jahr 2016 die vier Bahnübergänge verschwinden. Bahn, Land, Kreis und Stadt haben eine Kreuzungsvereinbarung unterschrieben, mit der die Verkehrsprobleme gelöst werden sollen. Knapp 27 Millionen Euro werden dafür in der Spreewaldstadt investiert. Die Eisbären Berlin haben das fünfte Playoff-Viertelfinal-Spiel gegen die Hamburg Freezers gewonnen. Zuhause gab's am Abend einen 3 zu 2-Sieg. Damit steht's in der Serie Best of Seven 3 zu 2 für die Eisbären. Wenn die Eisbären noch das nächste Spiel am Samstag gewinnen, sind sie weiter. In der zweiten Fußball-Bundesliga hat Energie Cottbus zuhause gegen den VFR Ahlen gespielt. Die Partie endete unentschieden 1 zu 1. In Berlin Tiergarten 0 Grad, in Friedrichshain minus 1 Grad. Netzeband und Eberswalde minus 1 Grad. Brück und Cottbus 0 Grad. In der Nacht soll es wieder schneien, vor allem im Süden. Die Temperaturen können sinken auf bis minus 4 Grad. Uns steht wohl weiße Ostern bevor. Das Wochenende bleibt wolkig, immer wieder schneit es in ganz Berlin und Brandenburg. Tagsüber morgen gibt es maximal plus 5 Grad. Autobahn 2 Magdeburg Richtung Berlin. Es gibt Stau zwischen Wollin und Dreieck Werder. Autobahn 10 Südlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz. Es gibt Stau zwischen Dreieck Werder und Dreieck Potsdam. Autobahn 12 Berlin Richtung Frankfurt. Zwischen Biegener Hellen und Frankfurt West gibt es einen Lkw-Stau in Richtung Polen. Bundesstraße 96, der Tunnel Tiergarten in Berlin, ist wegen Wartungsarbeiten vom Reich Piedschufer bis zur Heidestraße gesperrt. Und bei der Berliner S-Bahn fahren die Züge der Linie S1 bis Sonntag Betriebsschluss nicht. Zwischen Wannsee und Sundgauer Straße, hier sind Busse im Einsatz. Gute Fahrt.
Danke Philipp, sechs Minuten nach halb zwölf.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und wenn ihr Fritz als App auf eurem Handy wollt, dann holt euch jetzt die Fritz App. Kostenlos jetzt in eure Google Play und App.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Chaos Radio 188 ist hier. Wir reden über Router.
Sozusagen der digitale Bordcomputer zu Hause.
Aber cool, ich hätte auch gedacht, dass wir längst aus den Nachrichten gerade haben was gehört, dass wir jetzt nicht mehr so lange zur ISS fliegen. Also wir können mittlerweile innerhalb 6 Stunden zur ISS fliegen, weil die Rakete sich selbst rechnet.
Ich dachte, die hätten da schon eh immer so noch ein Computer mit an Bord, der irgendwie guckt wie...
Ja, aber der war analog.
Also analoger Bordcomputer? Genau, analoger Bordcomputer mit Röhren.
Röhrkarten, Röhren und so. Tierisch stromgefressen, das scheiß Ding. Also diese riesigen Raketen, also diese riesigen Triebwerke, also diese Tanks.
Die waren eigentlich nur um die Konkrete her.
Wie die Standheizung, so musst du dir das vorstellen.
Aber irgendwie statt zwei Tagen jetzt in sechs Stunden und alles macht der Computer an Bord, what could possibly go wrong?
Ist geil, aber da kann man endlich mal zum Urlaub hochfliegen. Ich meine, sechs Stunden, hä?
Franz Faz geht das immer so.
Ich meine, zwei Tage weg kriegt man zu viel Urlaub, aber ich meine, sechs Stunden ist doch mal ein schöner Daytrip.
Ja, das kannst du so, einmal Krankenschein holen und ab.
Wo kann man das schreiben?
Aber hat eigentlich schon jemand versucht, oder daran gedacht sicherlich, aber hat schon mal jemand versucht, eigentlich aus all den Routern, die so rumstehen, ein eigenes Internet zu bauen? Also eigentlich wäre das doch möglich. Ich müsste doch im Grunde nur genug Router, die nah genug beieinander stehen, irgendwie miteinander.
Du meinst, so per WLAN versuchen, so zu meschen.
Das finde ich ja mal ein interessantes Experiment.
Ja, da gab es schon, also das war doch nicht so ein eigenes Internet, aber es ist so...
Das ist halt ein LAN.
Siehst du wie Berlin Rufnet oder so?
Ja, es gibt auch Freifunk als Initiative.
Ja, die versuchen einfach wirklich...
Aber die Freifunker machen doch, die machen nur Internet.
Ja, die meschen sich auch und das Internet geht dann bei allen, die da eine DSL-Leitung oder vielleicht noch eine analoge Leitung haben, aber zumindest, wenn wir dann ans richtige Internet angeschlossen sind, geht es dann an mehreren Punkten da rein und wird dann über WLAN verteilt. Das gibt es schon, ja.
Störerhaftung jetzt wieder, ne?
Störerhaftung, so ein Reizwort.
Reizwort Störerhaftung. Kommen wir zurück zu den Sachen ohne Reizwörter.
Aber es gab diesen Fall, wo DSL Modems sich gegenseitig gesehen haben, sodass ich als einziger Rechner hinter meinem DSL Modem irgendwie Samba und Windows Shares gesehen hab, weil meine Nachbarn am selben D-Slam, also an derselben Büchse am Straßenrand angeschlossen waren. Genau, und dann ein großes Intranet existierte.
Das war aber Zufall, oder? Das war nicht zu gehört.
Das war nicht gewollt, nein. Ich war es nicht.
Nee, aber es ist tatsächlich auch eine deutsche Eigenheit, dass hier so PPPUE gesprochen wird, also dass man über diese Verbindung, die man zu seinem Provider hat, noch mal eine Verbindung aufbaut, um ins Internet zu kommen.
Das hab ich nie verstanden.
Mir ist ganz einfach. Das muss irgendwo in deren Infrastruktur und in deren Prozesse reinpassen. Du hast dich vorher auch mit deinem analogen Modem und mit ESDN via PPP eingewählt.
Ja, eben, das ist ja so Teil ab.
Und das haben sie eins zu eins umgesetzt, weil da kannst du auch über eine Anbindung zu mehreren Anbietern kommen. Also kannst du einen PPP-Account bei der Telekom haben. Du kannst einen bei deinem kleinen Hinterhof-ISP haben, der dann von der Telekom zum Beispiel die Vorleistung bezieht. PPP und so weiter. Das nennt sich ZISP. Das heißt, die Telekom gibt dem dann die Verbindungen weiter, die die Kunden aufbauen. Sprich, du baust deine PPP-Verbindung über dein DSL Modem auf und bekommst dann nicht Pakete von der Telekom, sondern von diesem Anbieter. Das ist also ein Feature dieser feinen, granularen Reseller-Struktur. Du kannst als anderer Anbieter aber auch dir entweder nur den blanken Draht, das kostet um den Zehner im Monat, von der Telekom kaufen, musst dann aber dein eigenes Equipment in die Vermittlungsstelle stellen oder in den Outdoor-Di-Slam. Gibt auch noch diverse Mischformen dazwischen, die dann unterschiedlich anders funktionieren. In anderen Ländern hast du einfach Internet, wenn das Ding ran, ohne irgendwie Zugangsdaten, sondern da liegt halt auf deinem Port Internet. Da brauchst du dich nicht mehr einwählen oder irgendwo eine Verbindung zu einem PPC aufbauen, sondern da, ja.
So weiß ich das wenigstens auch mal.
Aber hast du zumindest dein Gefühl, dass ich nicht getrübt ist?
Ja, das kam mir irgendwie komisch vor, weil, ja.
Das ist schon ein bisschen wirr. Ich hab ja bei mir zu Hause auch versucht, das über dieselbe Netzwerkkarte da hinzubekommen, so sein internes Netzwerk oder sein externes Netzwerk einfach dann auf derselben Netzwerkkarte abzufeiern, oder wie PPPoE darauf zu sprechen. Da raten sie einem aber auch immer von ab. Und aus gutem Grund, weil, naja, das wird jetzt zu technisch.
Sollten zwar Fehler da sein, aber kann man sich nicht wirklich drauf verlassen.
Kann ruhig technisch werden. Es hören ja nicht nur so Schwachsinnige wie ich so zu, sondern auch Leute, die das verstehen.
Und im Fall von Kabel ist das tatsächlich auch so. So DOCSIS, das Kabelprotokoll, da sieht man schon das öfteren andere Teilnehmer und fremder, fremder Leute, Datagrams auf dem Port. Also da will man eigentlich schon so ein Plastorouter dazwischen hängen.
Du kannst also gucken, was deine Nachbarn klicken, ohne in deren WLAN unterwegs zu sein. Finde ich aber auch nur zu gerecht, wenn die blöden Puppe einfach ihre WLANs alle zu machen, dann muss man halt woanders lang. Dann muss man, ja, ja. Aber es ist ja sowieso diese WLAN-Benennung, da gibt es ja immer so die Leute, die da einfach so neben in die Ecke stellen, anschalten und das beibehalten.
Kauft ihr selber WLAN, hab ich mal, nee, kauft ihr selber Internet, hab ich mal an einem WLAN gesehen.
Ja, ich hab mal gesehen, wir können euch poppen hören. Ja, und inzwischen möchte ja auch Google, dass man seinen WLAN noch umbenennt, wenn man nicht von denen erfasst werden möchte. Die fahren mit diesen Autos rum und gucken, welche Ideas dagegen blasen. Und wenn man nicht möchte, dass die Geokoordinate mit seiner WLAN-ID verbunden ist, dann soll man hinten noch so ein Unterstrich-Nom-Map dranhängen. Das muss man sich selber opt outen.
Wusste ich aber jetzt auch nicht, dass ich das hätte tun müssen, wenn ich das nicht gewollt hätte.
Da die Pläne auslagen in Alpha Ventauri.
Ja, na gut, dann.
Und wenn du nicht nachguckst, aber finde ich auch schon ein bisschen dreist, dass die da hergehen und sagen, benennen doch mal bitte dein Netz um, damit wir nicht mitschneiden, wo du zu Hause bist.
Ja, wenn du der stärkste Junge in der Klasse bist, dann kannst du sowas erlauben. Der Lukas hat angerufen, Name Lukas.
Du hast gesagt, so eigene Netze bauen. Gerade eben. Ich weiß nicht, ob euch der Begriff Packet Radio noch bekannt ist.
Ja, finde ich super romantisch irgendwie. Hab ich mir schon mal angeguckt, was man da für Equipment für braucht, weil ich das so romantisch fand und hab dann gedacht, oh nee, das verstehe ich nicht.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch, ich meine, das war so 1K2, 9K6. Das ist ja auch nur ein bisschen lange her.
Ja, aber aus apokalyptischer Sicht ist das halt total geil, Packet Radio.
Das ist da der Weg, du lernst dabei, was geht dir ja nicht darum, irgendwie in Zweifel, wenn die Welt untergeht.
Ich wollte eigentlich damit nur einleiten zu, naja, man könnte sagen, Packet Radio 2.0. Nein, heutzutage nennt man das Hemnet und es baut tatsächlich auch WLAN-Hardware auf. Es ist ein eigenes Netzwerk, komplett im 44 Punkt und so weiter, IPv4 halt.
Ist das dann so richtig WLAN-Hardware, was ich dir unterbrechen darf, oder spricht dir da ein eigenes Protokoll?
Das ist einfach nur IP, ganz normal. Es ist im Prinzip, man könnte sagen wie Internet, BGP. Das sind überwiegend von Mikrotik oder Ubiquiti.
Und wie sprechen die da miteinander? Über wie lang?
Über wie lang, genau.
Und das ad hoc oder was ist denn da wo du bist?
Nee, nee, das ist richtig schon so wie sonst auch. Also Access Point und Client und dann werden halt Linksstrecken aufgebaut. Also ich komme aus Osnabrück, hier gibt es halt auf dem Uni-Gebäude gibt es halt einen Link ins Internet und von daraus geht es dann weiter auf dem Funk-Turm, also aus dem Fernmeldeturm hier in Osnabrück. Von da aus geht es weiter nach Bielefeld auf einen ja einen kleineren Turm, der direkt neben dem Fernmeldeturm steht.
Jetzt hast du dich aber verraten, Bielefeld gibt es doch gar nicht. Ja, also ist es wie Freifunk nur in strukturiert und mit BEP und so weiter verschieben.
Also wie Freifunk, nur Freifunk ist ja mehr Mesh und bei uns ist es strukturiert und organisiert und halt ja gut Amateurfunk, automatische Arbeiten in Stationen, also sprich mit Genehmigungen, mit Lizenzen dabei.
Preisfrage, wenn du sagst irgendwie Amateurfunk und Funk-Amateure werden dann die Daten nach Plane übertragen, darf man verschlüsseln, darf man darüber HTTPS und so weiter machen?
Genau, das ist so ein bisschen ein Problem. Man darf nicht verschlüsseln. Also streng genommen darf man auch nicht mal, wenn man da irgendwo ein Passwort überträgt, um sich auf so einer Kiste einzuloggen, um die zu administrieren, streng genommen darf man auch nicht mal das Passwort verschlüsseln.
Wer verbietet das?
Das ist der Funk-Amateur, das ist der Funk-Amateur an Usos.
Ach so, also alles muss offen sein.
Genau, auf Amateur-Funk darfst du, wenn du jetzt mal von Phonie, also von Sprache ausgehst, du darfst jede Sprache der Welt sprechen und kannst dich damit unterhalten, was du halt nicht darfst, sind irgendwelche verschlüsselnden Geheimsprachen oder so. Und das bezieht sich halt auch auf Daten.
Das ist halt so der Deal dafür, dass es Amateur-Funkbänder gibt, die man als Funkamateur benutzen darf, quasi auch exklusiv. Es ist halt der Deal, dass man das zwar jederzeit benutzen darf, wenn man seine Lizenz hat, aber das dafür im Klartext und auch dazu sagen muss, wer man ist und so weiter. Deswegen hat man ein Rufzeichen.
Dass man sich gar nicht erst heimlich zur Revolution verabreden kann. Funkerspuk, sag ich nur.
Für solche Linksprecken, also 40 km sind noch ganz gut machbar. Das geht zwar mit WLAN-Hardware, aber nicht mit den Mitteln, die ein Standard-Plast-Router mit Standard-Antenne hat, sondern da sind dann schon entsprechende Antennenpanel oder Spiegel nötig und mit entsprechend höheren Sendeleistungen.
Das Schickste ist natürlich, wenn man das als Funkamateur macht, dann darf man natürlich auch auf anderen Bändern als den 2, 4 oder 5, 5 hast du nicht gesehen, sondern da gibt es ja auch Amateur-Bänder in der Region, die man mit entsprechend modifizierter Hardware, was man ja glaube ich machen darf. Weiß ich nicht, wie sieht denn das aus? Fahrt ihr da Strecken, die nicht auf den 802.fab Frequenz brauchen?
Also die genannten Router, also das läuft alles auf 5 Gigahertz. Einfach weil, man kann da zwar basteln, aber das ist preislich einfach, ja.
Aber schwierig dann Antennen zu bekommen, passende und so weiter.
Nicht das Problem, Antennen basteln ist relativ einfach, aber das läuft halt alles auf Standard-WLAN-Hardware und billiger kann man es nicht haben.
Ja gut, aber die Standard-WLAN-Hardware, also gerade ATRs und so weiter, gibt es ja in allen möglichen Frequenzbereichen, auch mit unterschiedlichen Front-Einsatzpro-Kommerziell erhältlich auch irgendwie in 3 Gigahertz.
Also alles in 5 Gigahertz, man aber nicht in den, ja, Stückchen neben den üblichen freigegebenen Sachen. Also man kann mit den Routern, kann man einfach auch so, ohne da jetzt irgendwas dran rumzuhacken, die sind halt so frei, dass du da andere Frequenzen einstellen kannst. Und ja, damit kommt man dann einfach in den Amateurfunk-Bereich, der dann da in der Ecke ist.
Ah, verstehe, also es gibt da einen Amateurfunk-Bereich, einen Frequenzbereich, den man nutzen kann, der auch von so einer Hardware noch gespielt werden kann.
Und man kann auch noch niemals jeden WLAN-Router nehmen. Also zum einen halt nicht jeder WLAN-Router kommt in den Amateurfunk-Bereich. Und zum anderen haben wir da auch eine Bandbreitenbeschränkung drin. Also wir dürfen, was war das eigentlich? 10 MHz, 20 MHz Bandbreite nur machen. Und üblich da oben sind halt wesentlich mehr.
Also wenn man jetzt so guckt, diese ganzen N-Sachen und so, das sind ja mindestens 40 MHz oder so was.
Ja, aber wenn ihr da Ubiquiti-Hardware verwendet, die kann das ja, wenn man irgendwie den Ich Bin Erwachsenen-Button drückt.
Wie viel Treffe geht denn da durch? Was ist denn da so die verfügbare Bandbreite, wenn man dann wirklich mehr als nur Revolutionsbesteck sich zurechtlegen möchte?
Ja, also es kommt halt drauf an, wie groß sind die Linkstrecken, welche Entfernungen überbrücken die. Es bewegt sich irgendwo im ein- zweistelligen Ambit-Bereich.
Na gut, zum Nachrichtenklicken reicht das schon noch.
Ja, es reicht sogar. Wir haben hier ganz nett gebastelt. Es gibt eine Reihe Amateur-Funk-Relais, also Sprachstationen, die halt miteinander vernetzt sind. Also wenn ich hier in Osnabrück mein Handfunkgerät auspacke, dann kann ich mich in Damme, in Herford, wo stehen die eigentlich noch? Ich weiß es gerade gar nicht auswendig. Kann ich hier auf dem Relais sprechen und komme woanders wieder raus. Dann sind wir halt auch über das Hemdnetz vernetzt.
Also das funktioniert ganz gut.
Da steht dann hier in der Uni ein Steuerrechner, der dann die Amateur-Funk-Station koordiniert. Wo wird gerade empfangen, wo geht es gerade raus. Und so ein bisschen mehr Spielerei dazu, was man dann noch so braucht. Also es funktioniert schon ganz gut. Ja, danke auch.
Weiße Ostern, endlich mal.
Endlich mal weiße Ostern, ja.
Cool, da kann man seine grauen Brauneier verstecken.
Genau, Tarn-Eier in weiß.
Wo waren wir vorher?
Ich wollte auch gefragt, wo kamen wir eigentlich her?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Ich hab nur auf meiner Liste irgendwie noch Natt und UPnP stehen und wusste gerade nicht, in welchem Kontext wir das erzählen wollten. Ach so, na das geht vor.
Das Natt ist irgendwie keine Sicherheit und neue Geräte, die dieses UPnP-Protokoll sprechen, können sich durch dieses Natt Löcher schießen, dass sie von außen erreichbar sind. Das klappt inzwischen auch bei V4, dass Geräte von außen erreichbar sind und man da keinen großen Überblick drüber hat.
Natt dient ja quasi als Firewall. Der Router hat eine öffentliche IP-Adresse von dem Internet-Service-Provider und dahinter ist dann ein Netz wie 192.6.1 und so. Und man kann ein Port-Forwarding machen, damit die Rechner in dem Laden, also im Heimnetz von außen erreichbar sind. Und UPnP ist dafür da, dass Software das selber machen kann. Also dass ohne, dass man es merkt, bestimmte Ports und Rechner von außen erreichbar sind. Das ist natürlich ein großes Sicherheitsloch.
Aber es ist so, wie du wollt. Wenn du eine Bit-Torrent machen willst, dann ist ja so, dass du willst, dass auf deinem Rechner auch dieser Bit-Torrent-Klein von außen erreichbar ist, weil wenn alle nur sich nach außen verbinden können, aber keiner Verbindung annehmen kann, dann wär natürlich voll doof. Da würde man die ganzen P2P-Netze nicht hinbekommen. Das war dann auch der ganz große Boost für UPnP gewesen, als alle meinten, geht mein Bit-Torrent nicht. Dann gibt es dieses Protokoll, mach mal, geht nicht, dann brauchst du dir den Router und dann nehm ich den.
Oder Sprache über Internet-Protokoll.
Was ist das denn? Dazu gibt es auch diese Wählscheiben-Dinger?
Dazu nehm ich UPnP.
Na ja, das kann dir ja helfen, weil wenn du so was wie Zip sprichst, da gab es vorher die Unsitte, dass auf diesen Plast-Rutern so Application Layer Gateway nennt sich das. Das heißt, deine Zip-Anfrage wird umgebastelt in beide Richtungen. Also sowohl wenn sie aus dem Internet kommt, wird sie für dich umgebastelt, als auch wenn du sie Richtung Internet schickst, damit du hinter dem Nat erreichbar bist. Was natürlich nie funktioniert, weil das so räudiges Zeug ist, dass irgendwie, also, und deswegen, ja, halt UPnP, dass man sich die Ports durchreichen kann, unter denen man dann erreichbar ist.
Das Toll an der Lösung ist aber, dass du nur ein einziges Telefon in deinem Heimnetzwerk haben kannst, weil es nur einen Port gibt, welcher dann weitergeleitet wird. Also du kannst nur ein einziges Gerät dann verfügbar machen für eingehende Anrufe. Alle anderen Telefone können dann nur noch raustelefonieren.
Das ist doch räudiger Unfug. Erst diese Application Layer, Gateway, Müll und jetzt diesen, also... Wie gesagt, das wird sich nie durchsetzen. Das wird sich nie durchsetzen, diese Sprache über Internet. Geht's jetzt los?
Zum Ende der Sendung geht's los.
Komm, hau rein.
Echt?
Go, go, go!
Nee, überhaupt früher ist der Ende. Das war Peak Telefonie, weißt du? Danach war es vorbei. So, wenn der letzte...
Die Peak Telefonie, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Du meinst so im Sinne von...
Da waren noch Ingenieure am Start. Die haben es mir doch Mühe gegeben, haben sich Protokolle ausgedacht, die funktioniert haben. Dann kamen diese...
Weißt du, dass du eine isochrone Datenverbindung gehabt hast, wo du deine Datagrams reingeschoben hast und auf der anderen Seite kamen sie in der richtigen Reihenfolge im selben Takt wieder raus, da saß so was wie Musiktaxi, weißt du? So ISD-Inleitung, um Radio drüber zu schieben mit MPEG-Kodek. Und ich sagte ja, wenn das letzte Musiktaxi desynchronisiert, das allerletzte Fax stottert und überhaupt dann werdet ihr merken, dass man über IP nicht telefonieren kann.
Aber das Telefon ist ruhiger.
Es funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut mit diesem IP-Telefonieren. Also ich hab da jetzt bisher...
Da bist alle deine Nachbarn auch noch bitter und machen wollen und du dann...
Dann ist Schluss.
Ja.
Er sagt, du hast noch ne Minute Zeit, komm! Ich mein, Nibbler...
Nibbler hält sich gerade den Mund zu.
Ich verstehe aber nicht warum.
Er läuft ein bisschen rot an.
Ja, weil er sich den Mund zuhält.
Ja, weil die Lösung dafür ist, da dann einfach zu shapen. Rein zu gucken, was machen die Leute da eigentlich? Und sich dann dementsprechend die Verbindung aussuchen, die man den Benutzern da erlaubt, in voller Geschwindigkeit durchzuführen und mit wenig Latenz und das ist ja dann schon der Anfang vom Ende, wo so mit DPI nachgeguckt wird, was dürfen denn unsere Kunden da und der ISP sich dann aussucht? Und wenn er da erstmal so weit ist, dann fängt er auch an, wie die Telekom jetzt da mit diesem Testballon zu sagen, ja und ab so und so viel verbrauchter Traffic, die Bandbreite irgendwie auf halb DSL zurückgefahren. Aber ja, unsere tollen Angebote da aus unserer Mediathek, die kannst du weiter benutzen. Und dann ist glaube ich das Ende der Netzneutralität irgendwie schneller erreicht, als man sich das gedacht hätte.
Aber ISDN ist tot, oder?
Ist Facebook jetzt aus, oder?
Ja, die Telekom ist los werden, weil sie für ihre EVSD ist, also ihr elektronisches Wehrsystem digital oder die S12 von, also eines von sieben, das andere von Alcatel, keine Hardware mehr bekommen und keinen Support. Das ist so ein bisschen wie die Concord. Ist zwar eigentlich geiler Scheiß, aber ja, ist halt, wenn man halt und, ja, geht halt immer mehr hin dazu, dass du halt nicht nur deinen Internetanschluss hast, sondern dass über diesen Breitbandanschluss, die auch alle möglichen anderen Dienste feilgeboten werden, und dass es scheinbar günstiger ist, dann dann WIP zu deployen, weil, ja, ist günstiger und für das eine Prozent, was dann Probleme damit hat, weil bestimmte Dienste nicht mehr funktionieren, die haben dann halt Pech gehabt.
Das war Chaosradio 188. Es ging um Router. Im Studio waren Nibbler, Mirko und Erdgeist. Und der Nibbler hat sich zum Schluss noch ein Lied ausgesucht. Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, dass du das jetzt anmoderierst. Aber nee.
Es handelt sich um Mavaren. Was machst du da?
Warum bist du gerade zu mir gekommen? Was ist denn da los? Ist das... Frechheit! Was hören wir jetzt, Nibbler?
Musik. Mavaren, Mancini, The Pink Panther Theme. In einem schicken Remix.
Chaosradio 189 am letzten Donnerstag im April auf allen Frequenzen von Fritz. Tschüss und danke für die Aufmerksamkeit.